this wilderness is the last true
wilderness left in North America there's
there is no other true wilderness left
but right here in the Arctic of Alaska
that's it a rifle or a pistol to me is
no different than a hammer it is to a
carpenter I'm a subsistence hunter and
this is just an everyday thing for me
we're gonna move along slowly and see if
we can get in a good range here to get a
shot we've spotted a medium-sized herd
of caribou Organic target a dry cow cow
without a calf that's the the best meat
at this time of year that's the fattest
animal and the meat is what's important
to us
dud my firing pin froze check it apart
add to you some grease that doesn't free
so easily I think the guns gonna work
well hopefully we'll have some success I
eat meat every single meal every single
day I buy absolutely no meat whatsoever
from the store every bit of the meat
that I eat is harvested by myself I love
it
the bait is placed in the back of the
cubby the animal comes along he sees the
bait in the back he goes in he hits this
trigger mechanism it's real humane way
to harvest Wolverine safety is now off
that is a not very powerful trap that's
what happens
Jesus Christ that's powerful use my
handy trap shutter here and try not to
freak now there's a learning curve I'm
just trying to have that curve not
including me snapping my freaking arm
and I try to use a lot of caution pretty
cold right now
it's about 20 below zero oh that wasn't
cool all I caught my hand in it doesn't
feel particularly good you can get
yourself in trouble out here so learned
a good lesson here with these three 30s
for freaking dangerous I'm happy all the
head was my hand left water jugs empty
make a run down to the river here and
it's water a little bit different than
getting water anywhere else you know it
just flip on the faucet the river
conditions just like some other
conditions here in the Arctic do they
control everything sometimes it's real
easy to get water the time it's very
difficult sometimes it's kinda it's kind
of dangerous depending on the ice
condition we're standing on a little bit
of shelf ice here the water level is
actually lower than the bottom of the
ice so there's error between the water
always the danger of breaking the whole
shelf a lot of people make a lot of fuss
about way I live I think that it so far
I didn't like it I wouldn't do this this
doesn't bother me I like being outside
it's a nice life